אני הולך ללמד אתכם על כדור מסתובב חוץ מזה שזה לא כדור וזה לא מסתובב היום ב-Qiskit בכיתה
נדבר על התכונה הקוונטית הזו שנקראת ספין על ידי התבוננות בניסוי שמצא לראשונה ראיות לכך
ברוכים הבאים ל-Qiskit בכיתה בסדרה הזו נשתמש ב-Qiskit כדי לחקור כמה מושגים בסיסיים שנלמדים בדרך כלל
בקורסים הקשורים למחשוב קוונטי לכל סרטון גם יתלווה מודול אינטראקטיבי
שמקושר בתיאור למטה אז בטוח תבדקו את זה היום נדבר על ניסוי שטרן-גרלך משנת 1922
זה אחד הניסויים המפורסמים ביותר בהיסטוריה של תורת הקוונטים כי הוא מדגים בצורה כל כך ברורה איך ספין קוונטי
עובד אבל זה לא מה ששטרן או גרלך התכוונו להראות הניסוי תוכנן כדי לבדוק מודל קוונטי חדש
של האטום שנקרא מודל בור על שם נילס בור שהציע אותו ב-1913 במודל אלקטרונים סבבו סביב
הגרעין במסלולים בדידים והם יכלו לעבור בין המסלולים האלה על ידי בליעה או פליטה של
פוטונים לכל מסלול היה תנע זוויתי מקוונט שהיה כפולה שלמה של קבוע יסודי קטנטן
שנקרא H בר בשנות ה-1910 ותחילת שנות ה-20 מכניקת הקוונטים הייתה חדשה לגמרי כל כך חדשה
שעוד לא קראו לה מכניקת קוונטים אז לא כולם היו משוכנעים ממודל בור פיזיקאי
בשם Otto Stern שנא את זה הוא קרא למודל שטויות ואפילו איים לעזוב את הפיזיקה אם בור צודק
שטרן היה כל כך נחוש להוכיח שהמודל שגוי שהוא המציא דרך גאונית לבדוק אותו ו
גייס את Walther גרלך כדי לעזור לו לתכנן ולבצע את הניסוי מסתבר שהוא לא הוכיח שבור טעה הוא בסוף
הוכיח שהוא עצמו טעה הניסוי שלהם היה כל כך פשוט והתוצאות כל כך חד משמעיות שזה בעצם סגר את
הוויכוח מכניקת הקוונטים שולטת בקנה המידה האטומי הם לא הבינו את זה באותו הזמן
אבל הניסוי של שטרן וגרלך גם מצא ראיות חד משמעיות לספין הפנימי של האלקטרון שהיה
תכונה יסודית חדשה של הטבע שחיונית להסבר מגנטיות מוליכות-על וחלק גדול מה
כימיה היום אני אעביר אתכם דרך איך שניסוי שטרן-גרלך עובד מה היינו מצפים לראות קלאסית
מהניסוי ומה שטרן וגרלך בסוף מצאו ואז אני אראה לכם איך אתם יכולים להריץ ניסוי שטרן-
גרלך משלכם עם Qiskit ומחשב קוונטי של IBM הרעיון הבסיסי של ניסוי שטרן-
גרלך היה למצוא דרך לקבוע אם התנע הזוויתי של אלקטרון באטום מקוונט כמו ש
בור חזה או לא כמו ששטרן ציפה הם השתמשו בעובדה שהתנע הזוויתי של האלקטרון גם יגרום ל
שדה מגנטי קטן סביב כל אטום אז אפשר לחשוב עליהם כמגנטים קטנטנים בצורת מוט
הניסוי נראה ככה היה תנור מלא אטומי כסף
ושדה מגנטי עם קטבים צפוניים ודרומיים
פה השדה היה חזק יותר ליד החלק העליון וחלש יותר ליד התחתון אז הוא יצר גרדיאנט שמצביע כלפי מעלה
ולבסוף היה מסך בניסוי התנור חימם אטומי כסף עד שהם התאדו ואז
הם עפו מהתנור כשהכיוון של המגנט הקטן של כל אטום לגמרי אקראי ואז האטומים
עברו דרך השדה המגנטי האטומים נדחפו למעלה או למטה בכוח שתלוי בכיוון של
הקוטב הצפוני של כל אטום ביחס לגרדיאנט השדה הזה ואז האטומים פגעו במסך שטרן וגרלך יכלו להסתכל על
איפה שהאטומים פגעו במסך כדי ללמוד על התנע הזוויתי של האלקטרונים שטרן ציפה שהאטומים
בניסוי יתנהגו כמו שתיארתי אותם עד עכשיו כמו מגנטים קטנטנים בצורת מוט שמצייתים ל
חוקי הפיזיקה הקלאסית קלאסית המגנטים האטומיים הקטנים האלה יכלו להיות מכוונים בכל כיוון אקראי אז כש
הם נעו דרך השדה המגנטי הם יכלו לחוות טווח של כוחות שונים שדוחפים אותם למעלה או למטה תלוי בכיוונים האלה מגנט
שמצביע באותו כיוון כמו הגרדיאנט יחווה כוח גדול כלפי מעלה בכיוון ההפוך הוא
יחווה כוח גדול כלפי מטה ואם הוא איפשהו באמצע זה יהיה כוח חלש יותר אם המגנט של האטום מצביע
בניצב לגרדיאנט אז הוא לא יחווה שום כוח והוא פשוט ימשיך ישר בגלל זה
הטווח של כוחות אפשריים כל האטומים אמורים לפגוע במסך בנקודות אנכיות שונות הדפוס שהם יוצרים
על המסך היה נראה בערך ככה אבל זה לא הכל מה ששטרן ו
גרלך ראו במקום זה הם ראו שתי כתמים נפרדים לגמרי של אטומים על המסך בלי אטומים ב
מרכז לא הייתה להם את התיאוריה הנכונה באותו הזמן כדי להסביר את זה אבל היום אנחנו יודעים שהם ראו את זה כי
לכל אלקטרון יש כמות מסוימת של תנע זוויתי פנימי בצורת ספין שיכול לקבל רק אחד מ
שני ערכים בתמונת המגנט שלנו זה אומר שיש רק שני כיוונים מותרים למגנטים האטומיים אנחנו קוראים ל
שני הכיוונים האלה ספין למעלה וספין למטה qubit במחשב קוונטי
דומה לסוג הזה של מערכת ספין וכמה מחשבים קוונטיים באמת משתמשים ב-qubit שעשויים מספין של אלקטרון
מצבים אז אנחנו יכולים לבצע ניסוי שטרן-גרלך משלנו עם Qiskit וה-qubit במחשב קוונטי של IBM בואו
נמפה את מצב ספין למעלה של האלקטרון למצב אפס של ה-qubit ואת מצב ספין למטה למצב אחד
של ה-qubit כשחלקיקי הכסף יצאו מהתנור היה להם מומנט מגנטי מכוון באקראי אנחנו
יכולים לדמות את ניסוי שטרן-גרלך על ידי יצירת circuit קוונטי פשוט עם qubit יחיד שמתחיל במצב אפס
אז זה נקרא תרשים circuit שבו הקו העליון הוא ה-qubit והפעולות שמופעלות על ה-qubit
מופיעות כתיבות על הקו התיבות RX ו-RZ הן gate קוונטיים ש
למעשה מסובבים את הכיוון המגנטי של האטום אנחנו יכולים לבחור ערכי תטא ופי אקראיים כאן כדי לסובב את
ה-qubit בכמות אקראית זה מחקה את התנור שפולט את האטומים עם כיווני ספין אקראיים התיבה האפורה היא
המדידה שלנו היא אומרת לנו אם ה-qubit במצב אפס או אחד ושולחת את המדידה לביט קלאסי ה
קו הכפול שמסומן C החלק הזה שווה ערך למדידה האם האטום בספין למעלה או ספין למטה על ידי הסתכלות
באיזה נקודה הוא פוגע במסך אנחנו יכולים להשתמש בפרימיטיב של Qiskit שנקרא סמפלר כדי להריץ את הניסוי הרבה פעמים כל פעם עם
ערכים אקראיים שונים לתטא ופי אחרי 100 דגימות אנחנו מקבלים היסטוגרמת מדידות שנראית ככה בערך
50% מהזמן ה-qubit נמדד כאפס ו-50% מהזמן הוא במצב 1 זו אותה תוצאה ששטרן
וגרלך ראו זה תמיד או ספין למעלה או ספין למטה אבל אף פעם לא באמצע בשלב הזה אתם אולי חושבים טוב
ברור שקיבלנו שתי תוצאות בדידות ביצענו את הניסוי על מחשב קוונטי דיגיטלי שתמיד מחזיר רק
אפס או אחד וזה נכון אבל תזכרו שכל הסיבה שמחשבים קוונטיים מחזירים תוצאות בינאריות למעשה
למה מחשוב קוונטי עובד בכלל זה בדיוק בגלל הקוונטיזציה של הספין ששטרן וגרלך גילו ראשונים
ה-qubit במחשבים קוונטיים של IBM לא מבוססים על ספינים אבל הרבה מחשבים קוונטיים אחרים כן אז ביצוע
ניסוי שטרן-גרלך על מחשב קוונטי מאפשר לנו לגלות מחדש את קוונטיזציית הספין
מאז 1922 הרחבות אינספור לניסוי שטרן-גרלך המקורי בוצעו ההרחבות האלה כוללות
שליחת אותה קרן אטומים דרך מספר מכשירי שטרן-גרלך כדי לראות איך הספינים מתנהגים בתרחישים
שונים הנה אחד בואו נשלח את האטומים דרך מכשיר אחד כדי להפריד את הקרן לשניים שמתאימים ל
קרן ספין למעלה וקרן ספין למטה ואז נשלח כל אחת מהקרנות האלה דרך מכשיר נפרד
משלה עם Qiskit ה-circuit הקוונטי שמתאים לניסוי הזה דומה לקודם אבל עם שתי
מדידות במקום אחת כאן החלפנו את הסיבובים האקראיים שחיקו את אפקט התנור ב
gate שנקרא Hadamard כי הפעלת ה-Hadamard תיתן לנו את אותן הסתברויות מדידה כמו התנור
אבל הרבה יותר פשוט להשתמש בו אז אנחנו מודדים פעם אחת ואז פעם שנייה ו
היסטוגרמת המדידות שמתקבלת לניסוי נראית ככה שבה מחרוזות הביטים על ציר ה-X מתאימות ל
תוצאות של שתי המדידות אם ה-qubit נמדד כאפס בשתי הפעמים זה מתאים למחרוזת ביטים 0 0 או אם
הוא נמדד קודם אפס ואז אחד זה מתאים לאחד אפס וכן הלאה נראה שאם הוא נמדד ספין למעלה ב
ניסוי הראשון הוא יהיה ספין למעלה גם בשני אותו דבר עם אטומי הספין למטה זה אומר שבניסוי הראשון
הייתה לנו הסתברות שווה למדוד למעלה או למטה אבל בניסוי השני התוצאה כבר הייתה קבועה אז
שני המסכים בסוף כל אחד ממכשירי שטרן-גרלך השניים יציגו כל אחד רק נקודה אחת מסך אחד יקבל
את כל אטומי הספין למעלה ומסך אחד יקבל את כל אטומי הספין למטה לניסוי הבא בואו
נתחיל עם קרן של אטומים שכולם ספין למעלה עם ניסוי שטרן-גרלך פיזי אמיתי אפשר לעשות את זה על ידי שליחתם
דרך מכשיר שטרן-גרלך וחסימת הקרן שמוטית למטה כך שכל האטומים שמוטים למעלה הם
ספין למעלה עכשיו בואו נשלח את הקרן הזו דרך מכשיר שטרן-גרלך נוסף אבל הפעם נסובב את המגנטים ב-90 מעלות כך ש
גרדיאנט השדה יטה את האטומים שנעים בכיוון הזה שמאלה או ימינה במקום זאת האם נראה
נקודה אחת או שתיים או משהו לגמרי אחר לניסוי הזה
נריץ את ה-circuit הבא ב-Qiskit נתחיל במצב אפס כי קרן האטומים שלנו בניסוי הזה כולם
ספין למעלה ואז ה-gate הזה של Hadamard מחליף את קואורדינטות ה-x וה-z כך שיש לו את האפקט של סיבוב
מכשיר שטרן-גרלך אז עכשיו אנחנו מודדים את הטלת הספין שמאלה או ימינה במקום למעלה או למטה כאן אנחנו מקבלים
היסטוגרמת מדידות שנראית ככה אז אנחנו יכולים לראות שהספין לאורך X גם יכול לקבל רק שני ערכים
שאנחנו יכולים לקרוא להם ספין שמאלה וספין ימינה אז הניסוי הזה מראה שאם מודדים את ההטלה על X של ספין
שנמדד קודם כספין למעלה לאורך Z הוא יהיה ספין שמאלה או ימינה בהסתברות שווה בואו נשווה
את זה פעם אחרונה לציפייה הקלאסית רק כדי באמת להדגיש את ההבדל קלאסית זכרו שאמרתי
שאם המגנט האטומי הקטן היה מצביע בניצב לגרדיאנט השדה המגנטי של המכשיר
הכוח על האטום הזה אמור להיות אפס הוא לא אמור להיות מוטה למעלה או למטה במקרה הזה נראה פשוט נקודה אחת ב
אמצע המסך במקום זה אנחנו רואים שתי נקודות אז חצי מהאטומים הם ספין שמאלה וחצי ספין ימינה למרות
שהם נמדדו קודם כספין למעלה אז מנקודת מבט של מכניקת קוונטים אומנם זה מפתה
להשוות ספין למעלה לוקטור שמצביע למעלה וספין למטה לוקטור שמצביע למטה אבל זה לא כל כך פשוט כמו שאנחנו רואים
מהניסוי האחרון כדי באמת להבין מה קורה פה נצטרך להיכנס עמוק יותר לנושאים של
סופרפוזיציה קוונטית ומדידה וזה יהיה סרטון ליום אחר כמו שנשארנו עם עוד
שאלות על איך בדיוק מכניקת הקוונטים עובדת ככה גם שטרן וגרלך הניסוי שלהם לא הסביר
הכל אבל הוא עשה דרך ארוכה בביסוס מכניקת הקוונטים ככלי חיוני להבנת העולם
הטבעי זה היה אחד מניסויי היסוד החשובים ביותר במכניקת הקוונטים ששניהם הוכיחו קוונטיזציה
של תנע וסיפקו ראיות לתכונה יסודית חדשה של הטבע שנקראת ספין כדי באמת להתמודד ול
הבין את חוקי העולם הקוונטי פיזיקאים כמו שטרן וגרלך היו צריכים ללכלך את הידיים בתכנון
ניסויים ניבויים ולפעמים לטעות באמת אין תחליף לנסות דברים בעצמך
אז אם אתם רוצים לנסות להריץ כמה ניסויים קוונטיים אמיתיים לכו למודול שטרן-גרלך
שמקושר בתיאור תודה שצפיתם ונתראה בפעם הבאה